les signes de 2
faiblesse de la voix apparaissait déjà
depuis hier à partir de 23h donc à une
heure du matin nous étions encore sur
place et le phénomène continue donc ce
qui nous a confirmé le fait qu'il
fallait mettre la voie en sécurité à
savoir arrêter la circulation au moins
sur console et ce matin à 7 heures nous
avons fait le point et alors qu'ils
aient nous avions des déformations qu'il
était de l'ordre dissymétrique ce matin
à 7 heures on était dans l'ordre de m
donc des déplacements doux nom de
maintenance et c'est un phénomène qui va
très très vite et donc ça prend de
l'ampleur et donc ça a confirmé le fait
qu'il faut mettre l'autre conscient de
voix au service donc c'est complètement
mari et une déviation est mise en place
pour vous c'est lié directement où je ne
suis absolument pas seulement c'est ça
c'est un contest ça c'est incontestable
on a monté une cellule de crise avec
tous les intervenants qui de près ou de
loin gravi coûte autour de ce chantier
pour pouvoir fuir a suivi
ensevelissement parce que ça glisse
quand même assez vite de hier soir à ce
matin on a quand même une grosse
différence est tout ce que je peux
conseiller à la population c'est de ne
pas se rendre sur les lieux
parce que si dangereux il y aura un
barriérage qui sera mis en place qui
deux kits sera infranchissable et que
pour la population qui habite sous le
secteur
qui ne se rassure nous surveillons le
glissement et s'il ya un problème ils
seront les premiers avertis